foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
hi please welcome downstairs tonight A
tanking economy spiraling immigration
now the same EU red tape we've always
had is here to stay even Nigel farage
said brexit has failed so why is it
failed and where do we go from here
Johnny Depp Returns the red carpet he
can tonight but after his Sensational
month-slinging split remember heard
should he still be given the red carpet
treatment or debate that's Topsy Trump
on blundering Brighton looks set to be
the least popular presidential pairing
in history
Afroman this number is pro cannabis
Anthem says America needs him as
president instead you'll join me live to
explain why
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening Fernando welcome to Piers
Morgan on censor no debate has split
Britain as quickly and dramatically as
brexit it did more to divide these Isles
and the Roman conquerors Meghan Markle
even me the six years politics in this
country was no longer about
conservatives or labor right or left it
was leave or remain friends broke up
over it family split up over it the
voters are moving on ukip was wiped off
the political map of last week's local
elections it now has precisely zero
elected representatives anywhere in the
country reform UK the rebranded brexit
party averaged a six percent of the vote
and won just six councilors Nationwide
in short when it comes to brexit it does
seem like most of us are just well over
it but as much as boaters have moved on
Britain sadly has not we had the worst
performing G7 economy even Russia will
grow faster this year every other major
economy face the same pandemic the same
war in Europe the same rocketing
inflation and constant living crises but
nobody else had brexit on top of it the
long promised tidal wave of brexit
benefits Pete with blue passports are
now seem to be petering into a putrid
puddle even the Grand Master of brexit
himself Nigel farage now says this
we haven't actually benefited from
brexit economically what we could have
done I mean what brexits proved I'm
afraid is that our politicians are about
as useless as the Commissioners in
Brussels were we've mismanaged this
totally and if you look at simple things
simple things uh such as takeovers such
as corporation tax we are driving
business away from our country arguably
now we're back in control we're
regulating our own businesses even more
than they were as EU members brexit has
failed
brexit has failed
no benefits to brexit this is the guy
that sold it to us Nigel farage and it's
hard to argue with him we were promised
brexit would mean control of the borders
but immigration is way up there's a
migrant crisis in the channel we have
promised glorious free trade deals will
be the easiest deals in human history
where are they we were told the 5 000 EU
laws would be spectacularly described
from the statute books as we wrestle
control back of our Sovereign democracy
in fact it's going to be more like 600
and I haven't found a single person that
can explain what difference it'll make
full disclosure I didn't think brexit
was a good idea and I voted against it
but I also respect to the Democratic
what are the people unlike some of the
more Ardent ramonas and I later voted
for Boris Johnson's conservative
government because they were the only
people in that 29 election prepared to
honor the result of the referendum and
therefore to honor democracy if you
don't accept the results of elections or
referenda then you're not a democracy
and you can't be a Democrat now more and
more people are changing their minds the
evidence that it isn't working is piling
Hub and it's probably time to have a
serious grown-up debate on what we do
about this and a reminder Nigel farage
who says brexit has failed well he
originally said this
if brexit a disaster I will go and live
abroad I'll go and live somewhere else
off you go then I'll keep hearing that
rwanda's rather nice at this time of
year nige
well joining me now is the Reform Party
advisor and former brexit party MEP Alex
Phillips by the US editor at large the
financial times Jillian tet uh from
across Department welcome to all of you
good to see you all right Alex uh I
watched you the other night on news
night getting brutalized by Aleister
Campbell which I thought you handled him
don't live very well let's take a little
look at some of it which is pretty
painful viewing
when I say you talk nonsense when I say
you talk nonsense let me finish
all of those laws that you talked about
were enacted by elected British
governments and elected British
parliaments the fact that you in Europe
couldn't do anything about it underlines
that the sovereignty lay here so all
your lies about taking back control any
more money for the NHS Sovereign
lies to invade a country to accuse me of
dishonesty and you might lost the
argument there my dear
if I may patronize you even more
well good evening my dear hi I'm not
going to talk to you in that way because
Alistair as always events has been a
quite an intimidating manner actually I
thought was uncomfortable viewing
however on the central argument about
brexit failing and even Nigel farage has
to admit it's failed and there are no
obvious benefits here we are seven years
after that referendum took place is it
not time just to it nothing's wrong with
the many mistakes is it not time we just
let you know what it hasn't worked let's
try something else one of the reason it
hasn't worked is because no one's wants
to use any of the levers that we now
have as a Sovereign Nation to make it
why wouldn't they well it's a good
question you need to ask them not me and
you're saying the conservative party
that voted for this the conservative
party that won a huge majority on
getting brexit done which we help them
do basically you really expect people to
believe that that same conservative
party is actively conspiring to to stop
brexit being a benefit whether it's
conspiracy or incompetence I don't know
but at the end of the day but the big
issue here is actually the TCA the
trading Corporation agreement aka the
oven ready deal because that actually
binds us to certain elements of staying
in step with the EU which means we're
not able to diverge in in ways in which
would be very productive for our economy
so for example State subsidies we're not
allowed to give State subsidies to
strategic sectors to therefore render
ourselves it wasn't enough already deal
at all no it's a terrible deal right but
but we knew that but isn't the problem
isn't the problem that the idea of
brexit was fine to a lot of people the
actual reality of trying to implement
what it stood for proved to be in the
end impossible well one of the reasons I
think that that was the case is you've
got to you know turn your memory back to
the the awful scenes in Parliament when
the uh let's say The Establishment
wanted to overturn the result of the
referendum and all of this shouting and
screaming and you know provoking the
Parliament and name calling and people
going over to brief bustles from the
other side it actually made the
environment in which to make a
constructive deal almost just impossible
and at the end of the day we were on the
cusp of essentially losing brexit
altogether around 2019 Boris Johnson
inherited the ollie Robbins agreement
that Theresa May had drawn up which is a
dreadful deal it doesn't really diverge
from the EU or give us any particular
sort of you know powerful sovereignty in
the way that brexiteers wished and still
wish actually we we had
um and this oven ready deal had a slight
change to the Northern Ireland protocol
he said it won't put a border day in the
Irish the oven ready deal to be honest
was was a very burnt dish from the start
they pressed the wrong knobs let's bring
in Jillian who's been listening to this
across the the Atlantic in New York well
Jillian look you work for the financial
times therefore you de facto have an
enormous economic brain did brexit ever
make sense to you
no I thought from the moment it was put
on the table it was one of the biggest
acts of self-sabotage that we've ever
seen in British history
um like you peers when the vote went
through
um I was very willing to recognize the
result of the referendum even though I
thought it was a deeply forward
referendum and was very much hoping that
and the idea of brexit would be
translated into a policy for a flexible
Nimble open British economic strategy in
fact what's happened has been a backward
looking parochial
paternalistic type of policy that's been
you know defensive and hesitant so it's
no surprise that brexit has been nothing
short of a disaster for the British
economy it doesn't give me any comfort
to say I told you so many people who
were involved in international finance
and business were saying that you know
right from the start but I personally
think it's time for a pretty serious
rethink well you know anyone because I
think I should say sitting on the
American side of the Atlantic
um you know many people in America are
just baffled that Britain would have
ever embarked on this act of
self-sabotage
um and not realize the damage it was
going to cause earlier on and you know
let's face it you know Britain has got
the worst performance amongst the G7
um it's you know got really serious
fundamental economic problems now
um and a real lack of confidence and
apart from the damage that brexit has
done to the trading lengths
um and the competitiveness the fact is
distracted politicians and policy makers
and voters from really core issues
around where Britain is going in the
future with its economic strategy is
tragic as well yeah well you know anyone
who's uh expressing concern about this
the most recent uh you got poll there's
53 of UK voters now I think brexit was
the wrong decision nearly a fifth of
leave voters think it was wrong to vote
for brexit 65 of people think the
government's handling the UK's exit from
the EU badly polling shows a 50 want to
rejoin the EU and so on and so on it's
estimated that brexit's cost in the UK a
thousand pounds per household and has
cost the UK 29 billion pounds in
business investment as according to the
bank of England
um maybe cost the UK economy 100 billion
pounds a year according to Bloomberg I
mean you put all this together I guess
the obvious question is yeah we we did
reverse our decision after 40 years uh
didn't we to you know the Europe
decision was only 40 years old why can't
we reverse it again it's been seven
years since this referendum
are we not a big enough a mature enough
country to say actually this hasn't
worked and to perhaps have another
referendum I mean why not
well I personally would argue the answer
to that is yes we should
um I know it would be disruptive and
distracting again but I think that it
would certainly get a sense of whether
the population the country actually
wants to stick with this brexit course
or not going forward
um but I appreciate that you know there
are plenty of people who say don't try
to open that can of worms right now
um it's going to be too destructive and
distracting yeah I mean I mean Alex
Phillips I mean if you get anything else
wrong in life it and there comes a point
when after seven years of getting
something wrong but marriage went this
badly wrong after seven years you'd be
heading Full Steam to the divorce courts
wouldn't you I mean why are we why are
we lassoed to this thing of brexit given
that clearly a it's not working and B is
now causing us actual harm and see so
many people who voted for it have now
changed their minds okay so I want to
make a couple points first of all
Jillian made an extremely uh valid point
in her first answer saying she had hoped
that brexit would make us a more uh
forward-looking and Nimble economy and
that's exactly what I I would have hoped
for as many as a smaller economy you let
Jillian talk I wouldn't mind completing
my answer if possible I was just
clarifying it's rather Nimble I would
use the word smaller actually
we've joined the trans-pacific
um community of trade which doesn't come
with the Parliament and all these other
laws and infrastructures which the
British people have rejected but we've
missed out on a big opportunity to do
things like take v80 of energy bills to
slash our corporation tax we don't have
AstraZeneca moving to Ireland to State
subsidized vital sectors so Tesla wants
to build their car manufacturing here
and we could prop up British vaults
through a state subsidy we've actually
all of the things that might have been
quite ambitious and the sort of
post-brex's industrial strategy and not
being done now look I'm all about
democracy and if there is a clamor to
reopen that can of worms who am I to say
no I'll probably end up back in Brussels
I would say there's more political
calendars I think there's Kia starma
ought to do it and ought to be calling
for it but he doesn't want to risk
potentially losing the election there
are other things that are not being
discussed openly right now that I think
we really really ought to be discussing
and one of those big things is Pesco
which is the common EU defense policy
now part of this is they want to Now set
up a common arms procurement across the
block which the UK is going to be
dragged into this means we can't buy our
own weapons for our owner Armed Forces
which essentially means we can't
determine if we go to or how we go to
war you know who we'd go to war against
and I think that that sort of
impingement why are we part of NATO well
NATO is very important and I'll tell you
why are we part of why are we part of an
organization like NATO given that but
you clearly believe we're so much better
on our own we're not stronger militarily
we're actually a member and NATO is
absolutely vital if you speak to people
from the intelligence sectors and from
the armed forces in fact very senior
people here they think that the eu's
plans to set up Pesco a disastrous and a
direct threat to Nato
what would it take for you to change
your mind what it would take for me to
change my mind is the EU being a trading
block not this thing that imposes its
own social legislation that imposes
Foreign Affairs legislation you could be
persuaded it could be persuaded to go
back into the EU well but not on the
terms of Freedom not on the
hypothetically fading block okay we're
getting somewhere along with Nigel
farage admits it's a failure you admit
you could see us going back in I think
we're moving in the right direction it's
going back in uh Jillian I think we're
making progress live on air here
can I say one thing which is that one of
the reasons I think it is actually worth
thinking about having another vote was
that
um the biggest strategy perhaps for the
last vote of the referendum was that
many young people in Britain didn't
bother to vote it's their fault it's
tragic I would very much hope if there
was another referendum that they would
vote because frankly brexit matters far
more to their future than someone is old
and crumbly like me and all the polls
suggests that it's a younger generation
in particular who are most upset by the
loss of being part of the EU and so I
think that's actually a reason to
actually have another vote at some point
or referendum to make sure we hear the
younger voice
properly because they matter I totally
agree but just on the matter of being
upset when you describe yourself as old
and crumbly how do you think that makes
me feel
well whatever you know the point is I
didn't have as much to take as my own
kids or anyone else I think you make a
very a very valid point I was actually I
agree so my son's all in my 20s I think
the most young people I've spoken to
would go back into the EU and heartbeat
but I do I believe in democracy I just
don't understand why you can get summer
jobs yeah yeah I just I just can't get
summer jobs in Europe anymore
there are so many insane there are so
many things that are wrong about the
lack of benefits of it's not just a lack
of benefit from brexit it's active harm
from brexit and there's got to be a
point at which the country goes enough
of the self-harm let's go back to the
country and if this time a majority vote
to go back in the EU well okay it's been
embarrassing we tried we failed as Nigel
farage says we move on gotta leave it
there Jillian I've got to stop your mid
flow I'm afraid we're going to a brave
but great to have you on the program as
always great to have you Alex and I
think we've inducted ourselves in a more
rational and grown-up way then you had
to endure the other night with Mr
Campbell the Beast of Scotland good to
see you thank you on Thursday next
Johnny Depp returns to the red carpet at
can tonight Amber Heard supporters say
it's a slap in the face other critics
have slammed it as a festival for
rapists we'll debate that next
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
foreign
Johnny Depp has hit the red carpet of
the Cannes Film Festival as a new film
Jean DeBerry opens the event
same on the red carpet you can hear the
end of this
cheer for Johnny
and he got shared when he went inside
the auditorium but it's been an outcry
from Amber Heard supporters and some
French actresses with the hashtag can
you not accusing the film festival of
celebrating abusers for 76 years now
Johnny Depp was Vindicated at his recent
trial in America with Amber Heard
ordered to pay him 10 million dollars
and basically exposed as a liar so does
Johnny Depp have the right to relaunch
his career or is Hollywood being
hypocritical by celebrating someone
who'd even been accused of such Behavior
had of course lost a liable case in the
UK we're joining me now is Nick Wallace
author of debt be heard the under unreal
story and the family law Barrister Paul
Rhone Adrian okay Nick it's an
interesting thing Johnny Depp welcomed
like a movie star as he has been since
he won this case in America in mobbed
been mobbed but he doesn't have a
completely clean slate because he lost
the libel action in the UK a judge ruled
that the sun basically by calling him a
wife beater that they were entitled to
do that so it's messy and there's no
doubt that this relationship with Amber
herb was extremely mutually toxic and
abusive it just comes down to how you
categorize who was more to blame and
what the abuse was like which I think
your book does it in a lot of detail
I think the point about Johnny Depp
tonight is should he be continued to be
fated as a blemish-free movie star in
the way we're seeing at the cam Film
Festival well I'm sure he would say he
had the right to do that having got the
verdict that he did in Virginia and this
huge wave of public support that
followed it all the way up to well what
about the other verdict in London well
this is always going to be the fly in
the ointment Mr Justice Nichol a learned
respected judge spent three months
looking over the transcripts the
evidence and all the contemporaneous
documentary evidence which he which he
did place a huge amount of weight on and
after three months he decided he came
down very firmly in favor of the sun
yeah Amber Heard was the star witness in
that trial he essentially believed what
she had to say and ruled that on 12
separate occasions Johnny Depp did
physically so where does that leave
where does that leave him in the in the
court of public opinion you've got to
say Johnny Depp appears to pretty well
be unanimously the winner well he is the
winner but as you know it's all about
the money isn't it and this has now come
out of the courts and is now in the
hands of the Hollywood Studios Johnny
Depp has been on this incredibly
well-managed Rehabilitation Arc since
last year he went on tour with Jeff Beck
was mobbed everywhere he went he or just
gave him a 20 million dollar contract
the highest ever for a man with a
fragrance he's co-producing a movie with
Al Pacino this is a really important
step on his own Rehabilitation opening
the Cannes Film Festival he's got
European Movie Makers behind him
standing ovation in the theater what he
needs now is to get to Hollywood he
needs Disney to say okay you can have a
lead part or a bit part in the next
Pirates movie should should Hollywood or
a firm like Disney do that with Johnny
Depp does he deserve to be brought back
I mean the hypocrisy of the cam Film
Festival it's an incredibly glamorous
event I've covered it many times myself
but they fated people like Roman
Polanski who's a fugitive child rapist
who escaped Justice for what he did so
they've got a long history of tolerating
this kind of thing they do say some of
the festival organizers they prefer to
celebrate the Arts rather than the
person which is an easy get out but some
people do think that
um where do we stand with Johnny Depp
celebrating the art and not the person I
would accept that if it was Amber Heard
who was on the red carpet I would accept
that
um I would accept that that we were
celebrating the art and not the person
if it was Amber Heard who hadn't lost
her L'Oreal contract I would accept that
that we were celebrating the art not the
person if Amber Heard wasn't hounded by
4.5 million people to sign a contract so
that she didn't get to partake in the
Aquaman 2 role but we're not celebrating
the Arts we clearly are celebrating the
person and this is what concerns me
particularly when we know that two women
a week die because of abuse from their
Partners
an American court trial determined at
the end of it that they didn't believe
it that she was a liar it is clouded by
what happened in London no question but
the most recent test of the veracity of
both of their claims about what went on
that marriage was an unequivocal win for
Johnny Depp and he has taken that as you
would understand the two to one wasn't
it it was a two to one but he won so it
you know in terms of the finances he
came out better of course than Amber did
what amber wanted was that unequivocal
win the same win that she was able to
obtain but she didn't get it on behalf
of the Sun and she didn't get it so why
shouldn't you be allowed to continue
with his career as I I haven't said he
shouldn't be allowed to continue with
his career what I'm concerned about is
the fact that they're not being treated
equally and what we have is a society
who seems to accept that it's okay for a
man to be an abuser but it's not okay
for a woman they have both uh sent out
they sent out a joint statement to
suggest that the relationship was
volatile they accepted that this is when
the marriage was settled but then went
out of her way to become a spokesperson
for gender-based violence right based on
her relationship with Johnny Depp and
that is the point at which Johnny Depp
said well hang on a minute and why was
she wrong to do that why was she wrong
to identify that she believed that she
was a victim of domestic
hang on stop painting her as some kind
of Angel Amber herb was not an angel
from what everything I saw did some
terrible acts of abuse both physical
verbal we saw it we heard it we heard
the evidence we saw the pictures and so
on she's not an angel in this right the
question is I think when you get a
situation that's messy like this what
happens to the main
people involved right and you might be
right there has been a double standard
Johnny Depp and I've got the pictures
now inside the auditorium at the Canton
Festival of this Standing Ovation job
listen to some of this my when one of
the first uh strong pictures hand in
hand
unequivocal emphatic voter support from
the movie industry but this is about
money I mean it's a huge snub to Amber
hurt yeah Amber Heard don't forget is
the only person in this couple at the
moment who's got a big Hollywood movie
from everything you've read is in
Aquaman you've researched them better
than most people in this fascinating
book
from everything you've gleaned here
where does the truth lie do you think
well one thing that I have learned from
studying this case and Reporting on both
of them on the ground is that no one has
a monopoly on trees not a high court
judge not Johnny Depp not Amber not
seven well this is this is where you get
right into the culture War because there
is an argument on I would say the
feminist side that can only be one
abuser in a relationship the concept of
mutual abuse which came up in the
Virginia trial is something that I don't
know whether colleagues of yours would
say does not exist because it allows
abusers to say ah you're abusing me
you're the problem in this relationship
and it can turn things on its head so we
have a real issue where people say of
course you can have mutual abuse in a
relationship Amber Heard admitted to
physically hitting Johnny Depp on a
number of occasions but does that make
her an abuser or does that make her
someone responding you know what I
reacting my takeaway for at the end of
it was they had a highly toxic alcohol
and drug-fueled relationship which
spilled over into verbal and physical
violence right and this went on for
quite a long time and actually they are
both I wouldn't say equally because I
wasn't there I don't know but they both
certainly contributed to the blame of
the breakdown of this relationship with
their behavior and so I don't see two
angels
um but I'm not quite sure where the
scales lie given we've now had two court
cases one complete exoneration
effectively for debt and the other one
the opposite yes and and and and that
sounds very reasonable sitting here in
the studio but what's the message that's
been sent to victims of abuse the
message that's been sent to victims of
abuse particularly women is don't speak
out if your man is rich and Powerful or
if you're lying that's the message or if
you're lying well in this country it's
not in America it was determined she
lied right so this is this is where it
gets more complicated you have a
Hollywood star Amber Heard who plays the
victim tries to cash in on being a
victim right op-ed pieces in serious
newspapers and does all that stuff
promoting herself promoting her brand as
a mouth shut peers I'm not saying that
but she have kept her mouth I'm not
saying that you're not her voice is gone
no no but your argument that we should
despite that she spoke out no no but
well she's entitled to absolutely but
then she's also Johnny Depp is entitled
to defend himself and he didn't win the
case
I don't think she represents taken aside
I don't think she represents your
average Joe victim industry so I think
drawing that parallel to me is wrong who
is that Average Joe this is exactly the
problem we have a preconceived view of
what an abuser looks like and having
that preconceived view means that we
then challenge a person when they come
forward when they speak out we say no
you can't be the one who suffered
because you look like this now you can't
be the one who suffered you're wearing a
short story you can't be the one who
suffered because you were drinking
alcohol I don't want to interrupt you
but I'm going to interrupt you
uh to say this but I recently
interviewed a young man who'd been part
of this appalling case up north where a
woman fantasized yes had assaulted
herself yes and then blamed a bunch of
innocent men and this guy went to prison
for several months and was facing 20
years in in prison but eventually she
got exposed right I don't believe in
always believing people or categorizing
everyone who comes forward right as a
victim well there's an automatic you are
and you are clearly telling the truth I
believe in respecting people in
listening to them and examining the
facts and see where that takes you
because otherwise you're gonna get
fantasies and people it's gaining the
system if that was correct peers if our
society was built on that fairness then
we wouldn't have had Rochdale we
wouldn't have had Rochester we wouldn't
have had the low stats that we know
exist in terms of reporting I remember
her came out with what she said she was
believed Johnny Depp's career went into
a tailspin and as far as he was said he
was an innocent wronged man and so he
went to court to restore his reputation
which he has a right to do and we know
how it panned out it panned out with a
lot of cognitive dissonance because
we're trying to work out how a British
jurisdiction can say yes he is an abuser
and a wife-beater and how the American
public and an American Jury can say no
absolutely not she was the liar in all
of this which is what the fascination
about this story is but when she came
out saying I was abused by Johnny Depp
his only recourse is through the courts
because he he couldn't do it any other
way and otherwise his entire career was
gone and his entire career could have
gone if you believe the American
trial because of a liar so it's cut but
it is complicated I'm not saying for a
moment he's blamed this I'm just saying
that I don't and exactly that but I
don't think she I don't think she is a
great standard Bearer for victims of
domestic violence given that she herself
was so violent well that's where I'm
sorry I don't but but also why why is it
that the canned jury have decided to
really push this film to put it in the
prestigious opening slot this is not
okay Johnny Depp's got a right to work
but let's just hold our nose and get
well the answer is look at the film
industry what's it interested in buns on
seats and money yeah it's not there to
make anymore the fact that Roman
Polanski still gets standing ovations or
and the first one was led at the Oscars
In Absentia after he absconded from
America to avoid Justice for raping an
underage girl and that's what he did I
mean the facts aren't contested and he
escaped Justice and escaped Justin for
50 years he is still lauded around the
world including in Hollywood as some
kind of hero I mean it's it is a morally
bankrupt industry when it comes to these
kind of things anyway uh this is a
morally unbanked book uh debt we heard
the unreal Story by Nick well it's
fascinating read uh it's an
extraordinary story I know people who
know Johnny here who absolutely love him
I know people who know Johnny Depp and
say yeah it doesn't surprise me I'll
know the same with that but
I have no idea Amber who's had to run
away and hide beneath the stone in
Madrid somewhere not Johnny he's allowed
on a red carpet all right we're going to
leave it there thank you both very much
indeed uncensored next Miller Lite
becomes lady's beard brand apparently
hell-bent on alienating his male
customers do virtue signaling campaigns
harness the power of advertising for
social good or are they just extremely
irritating
we'll play that next
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it what about one two
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
foreign
[Music]
facing a stunning backlash for a man
bashing ad the U.S beer famously used
Playboy models in his signature
campaigns throughout the 90s and early
2000s Meghan Markle of course went on to
be a suitcase girl on Deal or No Deal
fronted this ad for the brand in 2010
but the new commercial strikes a rather
different tone
here's a little known fact women were
among the very first to brew beer ever
from Mesopotamia to the Middle Ages to
colonial America women were the ones
doing the Brewing centuries later how
did the industry pay homage to the
founding mothers of beer they put us in
bikini
bikini look at this wild it's time beer
made it up to women so today Miller Lite
is on a mission to clean up not just
their shop the whole beer Industries
terrible aren't men awful awful women in
bikinis shocking who would have thought
any woman would want to be in a bikini
admired by men I mean it's just the last
thing you'd be buying a bikini ball
right it's parent company has trashed
its own Brand's mud wrestling catfight
ad from 2003 in its defense saying women
shouldn't be forced to mud wrestle in
order to sell beer
why not I thought mud was good for the
skin
competitive Bud light's notorious
campaign featuring influencer Dylan
Mulvaney and so far cost the company
more than six million dollars in market
capitalization I think there's a six
billion actually
um because uh actually it turned out men
didn't want to be told that they're
idiots and that actually this beer was
aimed at transgender women who were
biological males who pretending to be
women
so are they using the power of
advertising to make a powerful and
Progressive social point to these
companies or just deliberately
self-harming themselves by alienating
their core customers I'm joined by
former Levi's brand president Jennifer
say legal journalist Ava Santino I will
welcome to both of you Jennifer say it
seems to have been a run of these kind
of advers it goes back I think to the
Gillette Infamous Gillette one in the
wake of The metoo Campaign which is a
perfectly laudable campaign I'm not
knocking it at all but the Gillette
campaign that ran after it which
basically rather than celebrating
masculinity became a tirade of abuse
about effectively all men are awful
monsters unless they can prove otherwise
and Gillette lost I think nine billion
dollars off the bottom line until they
did a complete reverse ferret and went
back to celebrating masculinity again
and we're going to see the same thing
with Bud Light I suspect we'll see the
same thing with with Miller Lite what is
going on here why are these companies
surrendering to this well what Elon Musk
would call the woke virus
to say the right thing well I would um
you know having been in the boardrooms
and executive rooms for men a very long
time I would call it wolf washing
um it may be a cynical take but I can
tell you it is true these brands are
thinking if we align ourselves with the
perceived values of younger consumers
gen Z and Millennials
um they'll like us and they'll buy our
product we don't have to talk about
product benefit we'll just align
ourselves with their values so that we
can make money off of it
um and it's a it's a it's a virtue
signal to distance themselves from you
know past campaigns the greedy business
magnets of the past and it also serves
to conceal
um the last altruistic business
practices so it's a lie and that
shielding works the Press generally is
all in on it they're able to avoid
scrutiny from the Press by taking these
stances and they just don't think about
the fact that half the consumer base is
not not aligned they just aren't and
that insulting your consumer is is not
the way to go usually if you insult the
consumer they're going to reject the
product and they're catching a gigantic
Financial call so here's my issue about
this what is wrong with using sexy women
and bikinis to sell beer well I think
actually your your commentator explained
it perfectly there you are alienating
half of your base this is why would a
woman find that offensive well hang on
this is a person who apparently was in
the boardroom for Levi but doesn't
understand that actually women are
consumers and perhaps maybe they are
going to now spend half of the business
you're not answering my question why why
would women be offended by attractive
women posing in bikinis to sell beer I'm
not offended by attractive women I am
offended by men over sexualizing women
and I you know what you know what it is
a lot of men can't control themselves a
lot of men think that if they buy that
beer wrestling entitled I think you
celebrate Womanhood and it celebrates
the the beauty of mud which we all know
is good for the skin that's ridiculous
come on let's actually think what we be
watching here what to do with beer why
am I going to buy this product I'm a bit
you know why because it was a joke and
there used to be a time pre-wokery uh
when you're allowed to just have a joke
the women were in on it the memory on it
everybody laughed nobody got offended
now people watch that kind of AD and
they literally go nuts they find
themselves being electrified in a
triggering manner they have to go and
hide in a safe space then they look
marches down Main busy thoroughfares
because of a joke what has happened to
that light hand on matilla why do we
care so much why are we now going to
expose men to all these adverts doing a
kind of reverse assault on us have you
considered that maybe it's not all about
men maybe they're actually a large
proportion of females that would like to
see adverts that don't include why are
Bud Light why is Bud Lights market cap
just disintegrated now that's that's a
different that's a different topic
altogether I think we could I think you
could see there is some Merit in we
don't need to sexualize women in order
to
you sexualize yourselves in lots of
women's magazines and indeed a men's
magazine I don't think I did anything of
the salt you may not done personally
it's only a matter of time now that
you're a television Superstar uh when
the money comes from GQ off I'm I'm not
saying you will I'm just saying normally
in my experience
that will happen and then that is up to
those men to buy those magazines and
perhaps if they'd like to peruse it they
can but it doesn't mean that women are
going to buy them if you go around the
High Street and look at women's
magazines there'll be lots of women in
bikinis and how unhealthy was that on a
whole generation of women no now yeah
how unhealthy is that why is it
unhealthy because it sparked a whole
generation nothing radiates good health
more than a very attractive fit woman in
a bikini no that's not rather like
rather like by the way the way that
women have for a very long time drooled
over good-looking men for example oh
that's totally different oh I don't
think so let's look at this wonderful
advert for Coke remember this
[Music]
just
just for make love to you
tomorrow 11 30.
love to you I Wanna Make Love to You Ava
I mean that at you I'm just repeating
what I've just seen in the advert which
is a bunch of women drooling oh and
there's more and you know what I don't
know let's watch some more
love to you
all I want to do is wash your clothes
I mean I kind of if I was a lawyer in a
court case it would be I have nothing
more to offer your honor I rest my case
I think you enjoyed that more than I did
you know why I did this
I enjoyed it because of the stinking
hypocrisy no that's ridiculous and by
the way because if those women I know
and I suspect you would be like this if
we were off camera in a pub somewhere
you would laugh at stuff like this it's
just we're now with forced because of
this woke virus to take all these things
incredibly seriously to be incredibly
offended no one's allowed to laugh no
one can find these things humorous no
one thinks that women can fancy men or
men fancy women it's all evil how do we
get so boring over are you joking I
don't know if you're actually doing no
I'm serious it's all about a power
Dynamic you must be able to see that
those women well those women about the
men they are playfully laughing and just
it's all a good joke and we're all in I
love the fact you're trying to defend
this thing about this no no women I love
the fact you're trying to draw some
distinction between what we're watching
here let me bring back Jennifer Jennifer
this to me just I'm afraid epitomizes
the rank double standard
I think there's something that is in
between where we're not objectifying
women and I would say to Bud Light out
it ran just a few months ago uh with
Miles Teller and his wife that had the
trademark Bud Light humor it was funny
it it demonstrated sort of an updated
view uh to masculinity and what it means
to be a man he's a good husband he's
Charming he's funny he's dancing with
his wife and she's not scantily clad
they're having fun together
um he's not sort of shoving her out of
the way to get to his beer so I I would
agree with you humor Works in
advertising why do we have to abandon
that why does it have to be so worthy
why do we get so prudish why can't we
just also enjoy the male and female form
we certainly can and I would say another
ad which you may be familiar with in the
80s one of Levi's most successful ads
that ran in the the UK featuring Nick
Cayman for 501 strength of 15s I don't
know if you remember this ad one of the
most successful of all time it's a it's
a good sort of analog to the to the diet
coke one you ran because it's funny it's
cheeky
um there's little ladies that they think
he looks cute when he takes his pants
off in the laundromat no one's
objectified it's funny but here's the
other thing of course he's being
objectified but nobody cares men don't
care
product is at the center this is the
problem I'm not gonna buy something
because a female Brewer from 200 years
ago made it why do I care you know what
if I saw a good if I saw a good bit of
mud wrestling on TV tomorrow I go and
buy that beer instinctively
one
impossible
thing to see an ad that was actually a
bit naughty and a bit funny
that that that's fair I think bringing
humor back is is important I think
Jennifer honestly I think we have
forgotten how to love wokery is where
comedy goes to die and this is the
problem we've forgotten how to have fun
between the Sexes and just to have a
laugh little Saucy postcards on they'll
be coming for those next the ones on the
beach on the results they'll have to go
can't have jokes about things like sex
gotta leave it there thank you Ava thank
you Jennifer I appreciate it please can
we bring back some humor can we just go
back to having fun having a laugh
No One's Gonna Die it's all fine we can
just have fun can't we or is it all over
unsensitive next I speak to someone well
I think we'll bring a bit of fun if he
if he wins the White House the naughties
rapper Joseph Afroman Foreman is bidding
to be president and he wants to legalize
well we'll find out what he wants to
legalize after the break it's along the
lines of his hit song Because I Got High
thank you
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
please
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel nobody
use every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what about one
two
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk there are
predictions that migration could hit
over one million people before the next
election just stop oil has slammed as
Hypocrites for traveling hundreds of
miles to stop traffic and the main
problem for men according to Noel
Gallagher is angry white middle-aged
women that's all at nine o'clock
I was gonna get up and find the broom
but then I got high
um
[Applause]
[Music]
you probably remember Afroman's iconic
Pro cannabis Anthem because I got high
but after a man is back but now he wants
well hi office
an Afroman also known as Joseph Foreman
joins me now to explain why so Afroman I
think I can call you that your real name
Joseph Foreman but I'll go by your your
famous stage name Afroman you want to
run for president why
I want to get cannabis legal in all 50
states
so citizens and fellow Americans don't
have to go through what I went through
that's why and for those who don't know
what you went through explain explain
what you went through
oh oh okay I'm so sorry uh I um I had
the um the sheriff department the local
sheriff department raid my house with
guns drawn
um raiding my house looking for cannabis
and
they found like uh I think they said
they found some roaches like the ends of
blunts and some vape pens but I think
people should not get raided or almost
killed because they are using natural
medicine that God placed on the earth we
now have a number
a number of states in the United States
uh it's now legal to use cannabis do you
think there'll be a time in the not too
distant future where it becomes legal
across the entire country
it sure will if I'm elected president I
will uh I will decriminalize it
federally you know I will you know take
it off of the the bad drug list it you
know it will no longer be a crime you
know federally you know what I'm saying
right now it's legal in the States but
it's still illegal federally right but
I'm gonna decriminalize it federally and
one of the other issues that you you
campaigning on is law enforcement reform
you want mandatory body cameras for
every law enforcement officer if you
were elected president I could I I would
go along with that it seems to me a lot
of the more incendiary episodes recently
between law enforcement and particularly
African-American community in America
has come from people not really knowing
what's happened cameras of course would
be the best way to clear up a lot of
those confusions
yes uh Not only would I make sure that
officers wore cameras I would make it to
the point where they couldn't get paid
unless they had cameras on and then I
would appoint a group of citizens to
monitor the police uh to make sure they
are for the People by the people
you know this will you know cut out a
lot of nonsense and then I would get rid
of immunity I believe law enforcement
officers ought to obey the laws they
enforce
agree with that let's talk about another
one of your campaign pledges reparations
that you would single-handedly say the
U.S taxpayers 61.9 billion dollars
annually by ending the war on cannabis
and stopping all foreign aid taking the
money saved from that to distribute to
families negatively affected by the
atrocities of slavery we have Mr bait
actually earlier this week on my show
and here's what is my problem with it
really
sort of punishing modern day taxpayers
for the sins of their long-distance
ancestors for doing stuff that today we
would all agree was completely appalling
like slavery for example
where do you draw the line with that for
example I made the point that the
Vikings and the Romans invaded my
country let me finish my question it's a
fight the Vikings and Romans invaded my
country would we be entitled to claim
money back from the Danish people or the
Italians
okay I'll answer that question
I'm not punishing modern citizens for
the atrocities of the past however the
things that took place in the past
has an effect on African Americans and
Africans around the world in the slave
trade uh at this present time that our
present modern day problems
since the past
still has problems in the presence
because of slavery it's up to the people
that benefited from slavery whether in
the past or right now they are still you
know I'm saying living living in
benefits benefiting off of slavery
unfortunately we've run out of time I
just got your answer in thankfully we
run out of time thank you for joining me
good luck with your campaign I
appreciate you being on Piers Morgan
uncensored thank you very much uh
whatever you're up to tonight Keep It
Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
thank you
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking